is another way to figure out if you've
experienced actual trauma or not a very
good litmus test is if you like talking
about the experience who are you talking
to right now if you talk about this
traumatic experience allegedly traumatic
experience any chance you get then
there's a very good chance that it was
not really traumatic in my life I've
I've maybe had one or two experiences
that I think would probably qualify as
legitimately traumatizing I have never
talked about them in any detail at all
publicly and never would a something
like that it's not the kind of thing
that you want to present to the public
as content it's not the kind of thing
that you think oh I can I can use this
to get sympathy because if you're
thinking that way about it then it's
pretty clear that you're you're not
traumatized